a top trending article in usa today
makes a bold claim
claim is conservatives want to ban
transgender athletes from girls sports
now that
obviously is not the controversial part
the controversial part is the next
sentence
their evidence is shaky
our evidence of course is that they're
not girls
that that's our that's our whole
evidence but these guys here
don't understand what evidence or
science or arguments
are conservatives want to ban
transgender athletes from girls sports
their evidence is shaky what do you
think our
evidence is now what they mean i want to
be charitable i don't want to just straw
me in this article it's very thick art i
can't believe they wrote this much about
this
obvious topic their evidence they say is
that
you know some of the men who when we say
transgender people by the way we mean
men who are pretending to be women some
of the men you know actually
don't necessarily have this perfect
advantage because of this
level of hormones i mean for just as a
practical matter they almost always win
the sports but
you know but actually the testosterone
level
is this and because of that this that's
not our evidence
that's not our evidence the reason that
men should not compete in girls sports
is not because they have an extra
bit of testosterone or their shoulders
are broader their hips are narrower
they're taller they're fast
the reason the most basic reason is that
they're not girls and girls sports by
definition are for girls so if you're
not a girl
you shouldn't compete you don't need to
take any measurements you don't need to
draw any blood you don't need to do any
difficult calculations to understand
that bit of
evidence and that argument but what the
left does because
it is now so scientistic is it it
doesn't understand
what a what an argument is it doesn't
understand what philosophy is doesn't
understand
what arguments from human nature are all
it understands is this very
sort of rigorous materialist physical
process
that then they kind of totally pervert
in this way i mean just from a
scientific perspective husky hank is
gonna run faster than sweet little helen
okay it's just
that's just a fact i don't need advanced
degrees to know that only a scientist
only an intellectual
could possibly think that that's a
confusing or complicated question
but science because it has been made
into this idol by the left
it has to fulfill all the roles of
philosophy of religion of the longings
of the human heart and so it gets
perverted all the time
science is dead and we have killed it
that's the name of this episode you like
that clip go check out the whole episode
here on youtube you can subscribe you
can like you can go check it out on
apple podcast spotify google play and
stitcher and you can order
my number one nationally best-selling
book speechless controlling words
controlling minds this was number one
top of the nonfiction charts last week
thanks to you so glad people are
engaging with the book hope you like it
as well
we'll see you next time
[Music]
you